[MUSIC PLAYING]
I was an undergraduate at
MIT in the mid to late '60s.
There were very few
African-American students.
I really wanted to
make a difference
and have MIT be more hospitable
to minority students.
We created a summer program
called Project Interphase,
which still operates.
I was in the first
Project Interphase,
which took place in 1969.
It was the singular most
important academic experience
I ever had in my life.
Interphase invites
incoming freshmen
to spend a summer at
MIT, gain community,
get to know the
campus, and also have
a taste of the coursework to
get a jump on the new semester.
If you do Interphase, you
hit the ground running.
It's not for the credits that
you get, but for those skills
that you learn in those
classes, especially study
skills and office hours.
Oh, jeez, office hours.
No one knew about
them coming in.
But office hours
are so important.
It puts you ahead,
and it'll let you
know what you're going to
see during the semester.
And it really helped
me in that transition.
And to this day, my Interphase
cohort are my closest friends.
So they're the people
I hang out with,
the people I do homework
with, I study with.
I recall that
experience being really
instrumental in
helping me to feel
a part of the MIT community.
We invite departments,
labs, and centers,
and student facing
organizations to come and talk
to the Interphasers about
all of their resources.
How to get support from
Student Support Services,
or how to go to Career Advising
and Professional Development
and work on a resume
and actually interview
for job opportunities.
And if they are interested
in certain majors,
we have department
administrators
who are there to talk to them
about different disciplines
and why these majors might
be exciting for them.
Interphase was a nice nest.
And it's what I want to feel
like for the rest of my four
years.
Students who come
to MIT realize,
when they get here that, they
themselves are very talented,
but so is everyone else.
And that introduces
a need for them
to learn how to both give
help and receive help.
MIT is so much harder
than you think it is.
You have to learn to think about
the world in different ways.
Think about problems
differently.
Really figure out how you
learn, how to ask for help.
And that is something you just
don't get as a high schooler.
It's more than just being
invited to the number one
engineering school and having
access to all these professors,
but it's being taught
how to navigate it.
It's being comfortable
in your own skin.
It's feeling like you
actually belong here.
It's definitely a community
that you stick with.
It's not just something
that happens in the summer
and then you go off
into your classes.
And then you say
hi in the hallways.
It's a security net so that
you can feel comfortable.
It's a hammock.
It's wonderful for me to be
back here as a faculty member
and think about
28 years ago first
being introduced
to the OME and how
profound an impact
those programs
had on myself as an
individual, as well
as on my professional career.
I don't know where I would
be without Interphase.
Thank god I did this program.
[MUSIC PLAYING]